i never buy reality shows where people
aren't aware of the camera i was like
weirded out when people were like oh
you're just rom-com here comes
bridesmaids too
you just heard it here
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to the drew barrymore show
joining us in the digital hub is one of
my favorite directors of all time ladies
and gentlemen mr paul fee oh thank you
drew hi everybody okay my first question
to you i think of angley and curtis
hansen
and billy wilder
when i think of you all three incredible
directors who i never knew what was
coming from them next
oh thank you is that on purpose do you
like different styles who influences you
how did you achieve this much range in
your body of work oh thanks drew you
know what i it is on purpose i like to
do genres and my my goal is to work
through every genre in the world and
then i don't know retired i'll never
retire i like to surprise people because
i like to surprise myself because i i
don't want to do the same thing over and
over again you know how that is
i do actually i was like weirded out
when people were like oh you're just
rom-com like that's all you are and then
i tried to do some dramas here and there
and some of them were very fulfilling
and some weren't and then i was like you
know what i think i'm a little bit of
that sullivan's travels like i'll search
the world and come back to the north
star of comedy everything i do is comedy
even if it's something you know dark
like a simple favor that's what i love
thank you blake lively's so hot in that
movie she was inspired by my suits so i
take great pride that when we were doing
our first costume fitting trying to
figure out what to what she should wear
she goes i want to dress like you it's
like okay so which i love because i
really want her to have that style oh
that's such hot backstory because i love
her costumes in that movie there you go
i want to ask you really quick because i
won't be able to word it the same way on
the show but i'm watching the first
episode of minx right now
and one of your latest projects but what
is going on paul with
d we'll call it d
but i think you all know what appendage
and word i'm trying to mention
like should hbo change it to hdo
have you seen euphoria i know i i
haven't seen that show but i hear i hear
they they beat us to the punch if you
will when you're doing a show about a
the starting of a an erotic magazine
starting with men in it
you got to be honest you got to show you
got to show the goods so uh and they're
not so good and then you kind of do
think oh they're they're all the same as
she says and then you're like you look
at them on parade and you're like no
they are not it was our way of educating
the world to
what lies beneath but the the sexist
nature of how we idolize a woman's body
like we do not celebrate the male body
the same way that we do women why do you
think that is
ah i think there's just something more
aggressive about
male male nudity potentially also i
don't think i i'm only speaking from
what i've heard from other women say
that doesn't affect women the way that
guys do when they see like a naked lady
that's what i'm told i know but why i
have no idea but that's the big debate
in the show is is you know she says oh
who wants to see that and and they say
well actually people might want to so i
love that you're a part of you know
making a show that discusses that
um i'm really enraptured with it like i
can't stop watching it's pretty great
and how good is jake johnson
he's so cute too by the way um but he is
very appealing
will you please tell me about your
current other project um flash yeah uh
welcome to flatch it's a uh docu-series
so kind of like the way that the office
was uh following these two cousins in
the small town of flatch ohio and it's
just delightful it's based on a bbc show
called um this country and it's just
really funny i call it the comfort food
show because you laugh and you also just
want to just sit there and be in that
town so you don't blink twice with
fourth wall breakdown no i love it you
do i love it yeah i love the old movies
when you know you go all the way back to
you know the marx brothers and you know
groucho just look in the camera and say
a line and i just find it really funny
that king of the fight i find it you
know anything that john hughes always
did it eddie murphy like all yes
that you're right yeah i think it just
makes it's more personal with the
audience and also since it's supposed to
be a reality show i never buy reality
shows where people aren't aware of the
camera because clearly they know they're
on camera and there's a camera standing
right there so i'd rather have them look
at it and go like okay and i know that
their behavior is being affected by the
camera there
i've never thought of it that way you
will act very differently if the
camera's here than if the camera's not
here well in my case i've been with the
camera since i was in diapers it's my
best friend not you you're a family
member and i'm totally comfortable with
that have you done some films
yeah i really do think of the camera as
my friend and i've never
lived my life for a camera what i'm
having an aha moment about paul is that
the one genre i feel like i don't really
get that excited about is reality tv
because all the shows are pretending
like the camera's not in the room
exactly i say the only true reality show
that ever existed was candid camera
which is the best the greatest because
people have no idea they're on camera
that's why i married tom green there you
go yeah oh my god who
who i love i love him too and bruce
mccullough one of my best friends
yes i love the kids in the hall bruce
mccullough i think bruce was the first
person to put tom in a movie
in the crowd i think it was super
superstar i think there's just not a lot
of people who sort of like pioneer new
formats i mean i think when people
did things especially before digital and
camera in your hand
the lengths that they had to go through
in order to capture this stuff
was a big effort oh yeah totally and now
we just
take it for granted on our phone you can
shoot something that looks like a
million bucks anybody can shoot anything
and put it out everywhere these people
had to find cable access oh yeah totally
like we think of the wayne's world like
premise like people had to
find a way to capture it find a place to
put it out there and by the way this um
week's people magazine and their what to
watch
area has um welcome to flash and minks
both your shows are in there we did it
all i love that i'm so proud of these
shows for for completely different
reasons do you think there will ever
be
a freaks and geeks reboot and reunion
and
is that the question that also you just
constantly get asked
look i i love that people are still
talking about it it's over 20 years old
and you know usually stuff gets
forgotten so that makes me very happy my
instinct is there won't be just because
i'm so happy with what we did and i've
never seen a reunion thing that i've
really kind of like i don't know there's
exceptions to the rule it's hard steven
said he would never make an et2 yeah
like the i get it right like people want
a bridesmaids too which would be fun but
but think about it though why we love
that movie so much is about kristen
wiig's character going through the fire
and kind of repairing herself so then
does she go through the fire again and
fall apart again or we just have a crazy
wedding
maybe it's her turn to get married well
there you go
well uh-oh here comes face too
you just heard it here
drew got writing get writing right now
that's text kristen let's we can send
her a video we can make her a video on
the show kristen i think we just came up
with the concept now you and you just
have to write it go get writing
oh paul thank you thank you drew so much
fun
ladies and gentlemen this has been the
drew barrymore show in our digital
edition with mr paul feig one of the
very greatest ever
[Music]